what happened yesterday
what happened yesterday with one of the
most foul
disgusting uncalled for experience that
I ever had a discretion of taking part
of no one no one should have to go
through what we all went through
yesterday night witnessing one of the
craziest moments in YouTube history ever
now what is this YouTube glitch that
you're wondering what we discovered on
stream and it's really simple but it's
also absolutely crazy when you
unsubscribe to a channel it counts as
two people as two people are
unsubscribed so what you can actually do
is you can subscribe and unsubscribe to
a channel over and over and over again
and what happens to that channel will
repeatedly lose more and more
subscribers quickly and I'm talking
about thousands and thousands per second
I can't believe it I'm an absolute shock
it's with great sorrow that I have to
report that last night me and many of my
fellow YouTube comments were under
attack by a glitch they call it a glitch
I say it's an attack to wipe us all out
I was losing millions of subscribers
everyone was losing their subscriber
let's look at YouTube's response what's
up with that we've heard these reports
and we take those feedback so seriously
YouTube doesn't unsubscribe people from
channels driving at the core part of the
YouTube experience and so far we haven't
been able to find any underlying glitch
we haven't have anything use a line in
an underlying glitch it has become clear
that our enemy Atlantis the Butte bought
many times then yesterday I lost over a
million and who knows what's waiting for
me tomorrow
am I just supposed it here and say
that's okay I think not it is time that
we fight back it is time that we put our
foot down and say nein no I'm calling
out YouTube right now I know you're
listening I'm calling you out hashtag
PewDiePie YouTube fight at VidCon 2017
I'm challenge you for a wrestle YouTube
what battlenet once and for all no more
lies no more snuggling [ __ ] just you and
me one-on-one we will dip our self in
tanning oil and we will fight on that
day main stage of VidCon where everyone
is watching if I lose I will really like
it once and for all no joke
but if I we
I get to keep your site I become the new
ruler of your website
you have 24 hours to respond
what I got all my subscribers back and
more than I had before YouTube is my
favorite website on the whole planet it
is flawless and has no glitches in it
whatsoever I love YouTube and I plan to
keep making YouTube videos for a very
long time check out more of my YouTube
videos on my own YouTube channel thank
you guys for watching and as always
remember to leave a like and stay
awesome bros